[Musique]
notre seat du lundi soir avec Christiane
Bergevin Jacques Letourneau bonsoir à
vous deux bonsoir le premier ministre du
Canada qui annonce la nomination d'un
rapporteur spécial pour faire des
recommandations à savoir s'il doit y
avoir une enquête publique sur
l'ingérence étrangère donc pas d'enquête
publique ce n'est pas ce qu'il annonce
votre première réaction j'espère d'abord
c'est une tempête dans un grand verre
d'eau politique toute cette histoire
imaginez on a de l'information du
service des renseignements puis on
aurait fait une commission parlementaire
alors moi je comprends pas je pense que
ce que le premier ministre annoncé le
rapporteur indépendant aussi d'impliquer
l'office de surveillance de la sécurité
du renseignement où il y a une certaine
Marie Deschamps qui le nommait qui est
une canédienne numérique juge à la
course suprême que notamment enquêté sur
les activités illicites sexuelles dans
les Forces armées canadiennes qui est
vraiment où tu touches je pense que
c'est une bonne nouvelle puis ça
maintient aussi le secret de choses que
peut-être peut-être quelque chose qui
devrait savoir exactement en public
25 minutes dont 20 minutes de trop parce
que honnêtement on aurait pu donc on
aurait pu résumer ça de façon plus
importante en même temps je suis assez
d'accord avec Christiane sur la tempête
dans le verre d'eau chaude bouquin bon
évidemment c'est sûr c'est le nouveau
visage de la de la nouvelle guerre
froide ou de la mondialisation
l'espionnage tout ça puis il y a pas si
longtemps on a entendu parler des Russes
qui se serait mêlés des États-Unis des
élections aux États-Unis quand monsieur
Trump a été élu il a fait référence à la
France puis aux États-Unis justement que
ce type d'ingérence extérieure ne doit
pas arriver au Canada il affirme que ce
n'est pas arrivé oui bon on verra
lorsque le reporter ou bon ce que
l'enquête permettra mais en même temps
je trouve malheureux que pendant qu'on
parle de ça on parle pas par exemple de
la récession qui est à nos portes et de
la difficulté que plusieurs Canadiens
canadiennes vivent actuellement avec les
tweets hypothécaires les taux directeur
puis bon ben parfait parlons de la
présidente de la Commission européenne
Ursula qui vient la rencontre d'ailleurs
de Justin Trudeau elle est au Canada
cette semaine elle dit elle a dit
aujourd'hui qu'elle veut que le Canada
exporte l'hydrogène fabriqué exporte
l'hydrogène que le Canada
exporte aussi en attendant du gaz
naturel liquéfié que le Canada fasse
partie de la solution pour l'Europe
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cela ça
répète un petit peu ce que la délégation
allemande l'été dernier avait dit on a
besoin de stabilité énergétique le
Canada exporter vos ressources
naturelles le Québec mais je sais pas
quand est-ce qu'on va nous prendre comme
un pays moderne qui doit participer à
l'industrialisation à l'effort
technologique et pas juste exporter des
ressources naturelles alors je peux
surpris de son point j'espère que
Monsieur Trudeau lui rappellera que
l'accord de libre-échange avec l'Europe
et encore à l'Union européenne et encore
12 pays qui l'ont toujours pas ratifié
même si une application provisoire
depuis 5 ans elle aura donné
si on veut faire fonctionner
correctement cet accord là
que l'Europe étant demande davantage que
le Canada peut l'aide sur le plan de
l'énergie d'ailleurs madame est faite
campagne là-dessus on se rappelleraction
allemande est venue sur la question
d'hydrogène l'hydrogène vert mais je
suis assez encore une fois d'accord avec
Christiane oui bien sûr une économie de
la rendre foncière exportée mais on est
aussi autre chose comme économique
canadienne et
placer la perspective la transition
énergétique juste uniquement dans un
dans un rapport à nos ressources
naturelles je trouve que c'est assez
réducteur mais dans un contexte de
guerre parce que c'est ça le contexte la
guerre en Ukraine l'Europe doit se
libérer de son approvisionnement russe
est-ce que le Canada un rôle à jouer
dans ça mais le Canada un rôle a joué
puis on sait que le temps dit vous
dépensez pas ça au niveau militaire mais
quand on regarde ça on a à dépenser un
peu plus je pense que l'opinion publique
le réalise on a des équipements vétus
des avions de 40 ans des hélicoptères il
y a encore des six Kings je pense des
années 1960 comment peut-on intéresser
des jeunes à être dans l'armée
canadienne comment peut-on surveiller
nos frontières de façon adéquate
il faut intervenir il faut il faut il
faut peut-être contribuer un peu
davantage mais il faut surtout
contribuer ce qu'on a fait déjà bien à
l'accueil de réfugiés à la stabilité
mondiale puis à l'immigration le
gouvernement fédéral devrait augmenter
les dépenses militaires de 75 milliards
sur cinq ans si on voulait être à 2% du
PIB comme l'exige le temps en état 1,3%
du Canada dans notre implication dans le
temps je suis pas du tout favorable à
cette idée d'augmenter à 2%. le Canada
sur le plan militaire à l'échelle
internationale est un bien petit joueur
et je ne pense pas même qu'en augmentant
2% on pourrait augmenter l'effort de de
d'implication dans des conflits comme
celui qui existent actuellement au
Canada
ukra on prend 75 milliards puis on a
distribué au province pour mettre en
place justement des structures d'accueil
des programmes de francisation des
programmes qui vont permettre
l'intégration sur le marché du travail
on joue un rôle humanitaire puis
pourquoi pas un rôle le diplomatique
dans parce que ce conflit là il va finir
un jour il y aura une négociation un
jour espérons-le bah je pense oui je
peux inévitable on va suivre madame
demain d'ailleurs qui rencontre qui va
Kingston si je me trompe pas et qui va
rencontrer Monsieur Trudeau mercredi
cette semaine c'est la journée
internationale des droits des femmes on
va parler de la place des femmes dans le
monde des affaires la situation
familiale quand même sur les conseils
d'administration Canadiens on est passé
de 19% en 2022 2019 à 33% de femmes mon
éloigne de la France on est loin de la
France quand on regarde la France et le
Royaume-Uni sur les conseils
d'administration les dirigeants les
salariés on est loin Christiane en fait
on est en cette amélioré mais on est
loin pas juste la France on est loin de
l'Italie et de qui chauffent la France
alors il y a eu une modernisation
incroyable du contexte de gouvernance en
Europe ça nous a parfois peut-être
échappé à travers des lois en France en
Italie en Espagne un contexte
d'objectifs en Angleterre mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ces conseils
là maintenant sont internationaux ce
sont internationalisés l'Angleterre a
même des minorités ethniques sur 87% des
des 87 des grandes des plus grandes
sociétés des 100 plus grandes sociétés
en Angleterre à travers un rapport en
Angleterre on y va par objectif le reste
du monde on y va sûrement surtout par
loi et puis la France a est arrivé avec
depuis 2000 la fin 2021 avec une loi
pour maintenant qu'elle a atteint un
parité homme-femme sur les conseils pour
aussi avoir 40% de parité famille homme
dans toutes ces entreprises de plus de
1000 employés d'ici
2029 sinon ça va coûter très cher
un peu plus donc des des rapports à la
parité des obligations par rapport à la
parité moi j'ai dû l'organisation
syndicale où on a intégré des programmes
d'accès à l'égalité dans les affichages
de poste pour permettre justement des
femmes d'occuper davantage des postes de
conseiller de conseillage syndicaux ça
marche ça fonctionne et l'autre chose
moi je pense qu'il faut faire de
l'éducation auprès des hommes
c'est-à-dire que les chiffres démontent
que dans la sphère publique je pense que
le combat des femmes du mouvement a
donné des résultats ça fait quelque
chose mais je pense toujours je pense
que c'est le micro qui est tombé non non
le micro va bien donc j'ai pas perdu mon
j'ai pas perdu mon idée donc dans la
sphère publique je pense qu'on avance
mais dans la sphère privée je pense que
ce sont encore pas mal les femmes qui
s'occupent des familles des enfants et
il y a un peu d'éducation à faire parce
que s'il y a pas un partage dans la
sphère privée de ce rapport-là à la
place des femmes sur le marché du
travail ou sont des conseils
d'administration mais ça va être la
double tranche pour bien des femmes
encore longtemps ça prend plus de de
règles de quota pour assurer la parité
en fait on a une loi au Québec on est la
seule juridiction nord-américaine qui
était la loi en 2011 décrétée par le
gouvernement de Monsieur Charest pour
l'objectif de 40 % de femmes sur les
conseils de société de la couronne ça
super bien marché quand une loi là ça
prend 5 ans c'était l'histoire de la
France on en parle plus c'est réglé
quand on met le système qu'on a mis au
Canada suite à une consultation de se
conformer ou expliquer ce qui cause ce
Royaume-Uni on en parle encore 10 ans
plus tard mais juste un petit mot pour
les syndicats
mais vous savez quand même on a deux
syndicats au Québec FTQ la CSN les deux
plus grands qui sont dirigés par des
femmes et leur fonds d'investissement
dans les deux cas sont dirigés par des
femmes Jenny bayic et Geneviève Morin
vous avez laissé votre place à une femme
Caroline sanville la place à une femme
j'en suis fier et embaucher une femme
aussi comme PDG de fonds
fonctionne plus mais vous parlez
tellement fort dans la vie qu'on vous
entend quand même Jacques merci
Christiane merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI